our driver was crazy
the darkness is going into territory
that might not be familiar with and I
think it was really stupid of them to
you know if you thought winter had
halted the flow of migrants risking more
to reach Europe this rescue team will
vouch for the fact it's simply not true
setting off from the mothership
responder they've identified a boat in
distress in the Aegean Sea
it quickly becomes clear this is not
just a vessel in trouble but a boatload
of migrants who are drown the first
priority for the rescuers is finding
children who can't survive in the water
for long this woman is seven months
pregnant frantic efforts are made to
save her two children as her husband
please
the number of people being pulled from
the water seems endless and it's quite
clear not everyone has survived all
around this boat in the pitch darkness
you can hear people screaming for help
it's impossible to simply stand and
watch when so many lives hang in the
balance
in all three children didn't make it
a little girl aged four and two boys who
were both two years old these youngsters
will never know how close they came on
the night their lives changed forever
one of the last to be pulled from the
water by rescuers from the charity
mowers was this man reluctant to give up
part of a mattress he's been hanging on
to for dear life in all 12 adult men
five females and three children were
rescued almost all were Syrian survivors
are treated for hypothermia haunted by
what might have been
but for the families who've lost their
children words of comfort mean nothing
Syrian dr. Alan Suleiman traveling with
his sister's son Mohammed described how
their boat capsized abruptly I don't
know exactly what happened but our
driver was crazy and they identified
this man seen earlier hanging onto a
mattress in the water as the driver of
the boat
these peoples and me going through
Greece okay he told us his name was AK
Oscar and he was on his way to Greece to
get work
by first light we're sailing to the
island of samos but the atmosphere on
the ship has changed a skirt has been
put onto the deck separated from the
other passengers no longer merely a
survivor now a suspected people smuggler
arriving in the port were met by Greek
police who've come to arrest the
twenty-year-old from Turkey
three young lives lost at sea with Oscar
at the helm of the ill-fated vessel he
claims he was made to do it though
admits he has no experience of driving a
boat but before leaving the ship Greek
police force him to face up to the
consequences of his actions look says a
police officer Oscar tis now just a few
metres from the body bags of the young
children who died
he's then left to sit on the deck after
a while not wanting to look anymore
behind the tarpaulin the father of a two
year old boy is identifying his child
he's then led away seemingly oblivious
to Oscars still kneeling by the bodies
overcome by emotion it's not the whales
of the parents you could hear but the
man accused of a skirt now faces charges
of manslaughter smuggling refugees and
causing a shipwreck a guy who's old I
mean I was picked darkness he's going
into territory that is might not be
familiar with and I think it's really
you know stupid of him to you know do
this thing the survivors are given some
basic provisions as they leave the ship
what little they had was taken by the
sea these are the lucky ones they now
have the opportunity to start a new life
in Europe it's what they've dreamed of
but for those who've lost their children
arriving here is little consolation this
couple are now childless they have each
other but have paid dearly for putting
their lives in the hands of people
smugglers Lisa Holland Sky News Samos